what's the coolest stone you've ever
seen
oh my god there's so many
and what what what defines is it rarity
is it just raw beauty
what what captivates your i like
excitement a storied stone
i have a very beautiful fair burn agate
which is multiple layers
and there's something i call agate
paralysis because
to polish it
you have to go through the layers
which means you're destroying the layers
and maybe what should be done is it
should be like a movie where you you
film
the entire process of cutting and
polishing so that it's not dead
in other words what was the diamond when
it started rough the the rough diamond
is gone but if you could sort of do a
filmic version yeah of a cutting process
so that the
the stone would exist in a from a
pre-polished to a polished state all as
a kind of
nft or something
another that should be an nfc that's
right
so the other thing i fantasize about is
how
pattern recognition technology will
probably in the future allow us to
discover all kinds of amazing stones
including for example fossil skulls
fossil skulls of humans
now it's kind of a
chance process that you discover a skull
in
east africa but why not have a drone
moving constantly scanning for pattern
recognition
of human skull human teeth very slowly
and then on the surface you mean just
above the surface just 10 feet above the
surface 20 feet above the surface no
sorry you think you'll be able to find
skulls on the surface yes
yes in the middle of a place that no one
has looked which in these areas are vast
right
so it could be found on the surface then
move to the next layer then then find it
under the surface as well there's lidar
there's all kinds of ways we're finding
jungles and
jungle cities in in under the amazon
that people didn't know about
do you think there's something
out there that would just blow your mind
oh for sure
for sure
yeah no doubt oh man
and uh how much of it is a little bit
underground right or how much of it is
in the ocean yeah
i mean here right here we are in the bay
area
we know that
much of the native american civilization
here was under the bay
because six thousand years ago the bay
was dry it was a river not a bay
and so all of those whatever
material culture archaeological traces
existed there
are now at least preserved under the
water
so i think we're just beginning to to
touch the could be treasure too
i mean like literally like you said
we'll lose the wisdom or we'll lose the
knowledge but
i i mean um
if the if there's the pyramids right
it's the great wonders of the world
there might be other wanders that are
completely lost yeah just i mean one of
the stones you asked about stones i like
i
i like
stones for example
every now and then dinosaurs would eat
rocks
as gizzard stones and then you find them
in their in their guts and their bones
well every now and then they would eat a
piece of petrified wood
so the idea that something was a tree
and then stone and then swallowed by a
dinosaur and ground up in the gizzard
and polished and then left in a you know
yeah so i like things that have been
through dramatic there's a story there
there's this yeah i mean that that's
okay the the really fascinating thing
why
seeing allah or crosses in the stone
is it feels like the stone has wisdom
because it has been
there's a there's a
it's been through so many generations of
humans it's like bigger
right it's seen it all also it's also
the intellectual question of intelligent
design in other words when people say
intelligent design mostly it's bogus but
there are several interesting examples
of actual intelligent design meaning
when is a stone the product of artifice
and when is it a geofact produced by
nature
and that's that was an important
discovery in the 19th century
the the zone of percussion it's called
the
the percussion zone
or how do you know that a signal from
out of space is an intelligent signal
and as opposed to
hydrogen doing something or some
natural thing that's the genuine problem
of intelligent design how do you know if
it's pi
maybe if it's e if it's some
you know pattern
is how do you know that it's an
intelligent signal how do you know that
an artifact in the ground is
you know
we'll see in the clouds a face
it's called peridolia we have a kind of
a built-in ability to see faces where
they really aren't there right that's
why kids like clowns
you know we've evolved that so babies
evolve it to recognize their parents and
so forth
but when is it a projection
and when is it really in the in the in
the stone
and that was a big question with the
rise of fossils you know if you find a a
curly thing
is that life or is it non-life is it you
know
people have made this mistake before you
know they'll find a rock on on the moon
or mars they say oh this is a face or
whatever well
you know no that's that's just
projection that's paradoia i guess
throughout science you have this problem
of signal it just because something is
beautiful
doesn't mean it was i mean
it's that's not a good signal to
determine if it's intelligent design or
natural
evolution or natural design just because
you're you see a stone that just yeah
the pattern is is incredible
what do you know how do you know it's a
fossil is a is one question
namely the ex you know the remnants of
an organism
and how do you know if it was
manipulated by a human
you know this is a big problem in in
trying to figure out the oldest art
if you find scratchings on a bone
is that a tally is it is it someone
marking her minstrel period is it phases
of the moon
or is it trampling by an antelope
and that's that's called the science of
taphonomy to discern when a marking on a
bone or a stone
is in a sense a an artifact or a
geofactor an antelope effect
and that's it's an intellectually
challenging question and people want to
fantasize they'll find a stone that
looks like a carving is 300 000 years
old generally i think those are just
odd stones yeah you don't find the
explosion
of carved stone until around 60 000
years ago 50 60
000 years ago there seems to be
something that
paleo anthropologists call the
creative explosion or the big bang of
the mind that produces a kind of ability
to
to see in the distance to
identify a shape in an object to create
a shape and an object that you don't get
the neandertals
don't seem to have ever done what we
would call art
that's a very interesting
phenomenon
you know but it requires that you have
some understanding
when is something art and when is it
just oh that's a rock that looks like a
face or some not necessarily
understanding but a conception that's
mutually agreed upon right that we're
able to because
maybe neanderthals maybe fish having a
conception of art they just uh
and this this also gets back to your
question about
professional bias and ideology because
there's a huge reward for finding the
oldest art yeah
yeah if if everyone says it's 50 000
years ago and you find one that's 300
thousand years ago that's a huge
discovery
so
there's a there's a bias and this has
been one of the
things that's led to the
probably the over proliferation of
different species of hominids
because there's no academic reward for
finding yet another example of someone
else's species
but there's a huge reward
if you can find you know
a lex friedmanite you know
new you can name it after yourself or
whatever yeah uh new fossil yeah that
there's a huge professional reward to be
the first at something and so those
types of professional rewards
also influence science and what kind of
science gets done
you